let's go
ladies and gentlemen welcome to a very
special
Late Night episode
[Music]
all right y'all what's up
dancing too loud today because it's like
it's late it's like 11 37. Rachel is
asleep
but it is what it is I had to get my
podcast out so here we are game of uh
House of dragons She-Hulk LeBron James
Tom Brady NBA preview
short concise here we are look welcome
to
[Music]
all right what's up y'all
yeah so
um welcome to the podcast welcome to the
podcast
it is a griffin oh well actually it's
episode 207 so I forgot to change that
because I'm tired make sure you
subscribe hit the notifications share do
all that great stuff I'm on Twitch most
days I'm on Twitch most days if you want
to support the show you could be a
subscriber on Twitch or you can even be
a subscriber on patreon if you want just
to support the show extra content coming
your way
um Today's Show is brought to you by
doordash
uh that's for limited time our listeners
get 50 off up to twenty dollar value
and a zero delivery fee when you
download the doordash app and enter code
Griffin
fifty percent off up to twenty dollar
value and zero delivery fees when you
download the doordash app in the app
store and enter code Griffin more from
doordash later
ah hello everybody so what is going on
in my world right now I bet you wonder
why am I up here so late well I'm
actually this is a crazy week
I am actually shooting a movie Monday
and Tuesday which is gonna I'm just the
first time I'm not gonna be able to be
on
kicking a sting this week so they're
going to be doing that on their own on
you know I couldn't do it I'm shooting a
movie Monday Tuesday I'm shooting a
television show Wednesday Thursday is my
only day I sort sort of have off and
then Friday I go to Colusa Casino up in
Sacramento and then Saturday I'm going
to Arizona for a wedding so there was
just absolutely no time to do anything
this week I actually should have done
the podcast yesterday but I flew home
from Florida because I was out in
Florida with Rick Glassman and um that
was great
oh that reminds me of something that I
you know what I just that reminds me of
something that I want to talk about
[Music]
um
so yeah
I'm going to yeah all that stuff's going
on this week and then like I said I was
I was out in
um what do you call it we were I was in
St Petersburg with uh Rick Glassman and
that was really fun Rick and I had a
good time it's just fun hanging out with
Rick we don't you don't normally get to
go out go out with your friends like
that unless you're like a big big huge
big time headliner you know so it was
interesting crowds we did the podcast
and then we did like sets at this you
know uh shout out to uh uh what's the
name of the place something creative I'm
so tired right now I don't even remember
the
I don't even remember Coastal creative
that was the name of the place yeah
Coastal creative
let me make sure that's the name of them
yeah that that's it
yeah Coastal creative was whatever if I
didn't get it right I'll I'll put it in
the
um the yeah that's a coastal Creator
yeah so anyways I'm just tired sorry
shout out to Coastal creative and shout
out to other people that are listening
right now if you if you getting it later
tomorrow Audi all the audio platforms I
appreciate you guys please leave me
um you know reviews and all that kind of
stuff if you like what I do so anyways
we were out in Florida that was great
but something I found out out in Florida
that they finally announced and you know
I didn't put this in the description but
I really need to is check this out
Amazon canceled Rick's show
I mean can you believe this
um as we see it canceled after one
season
what I mean I don't understand this
you know
first of all Amazon you got a lot of
money
you got refrigerator money you got
toilet seat money you got
you know delivery money you got all this
money the dudes the richest one of the
richest men in the entire world
and You're Gonna Cancel the the the the
the the artsy show at a time when
everything's about inclusion and
diversity
so you're not all about that when it
comes to autism and you know you hired
some actors who actually suffer with
this so you want to talk about inclusion
and everything you need I mean the the
the the the the ratings of the show were
great High critics Acclaim
um the people watching it on on Rotten
Tomato it's like both you know what I
mean I I just I don't get the point of
this you know especially when
um they're gonna put they're gonna have
this boring
listen to me
boring
ring show The Lord of the Rings show
you're gonna so you and they spent a
billion dollars on their show
a billion dollars and it it's just it I
I don't think any of us care but you're
gonna cancel so it's no the Orcs
it's yes to Orcs And no to autism that's
what I don't understand it and then they
had them out here
freaking winning Awards the show was
winning these like awards from different
organizations and stuff and then they
knew they were going to cancel it and
didn't say nothing you know they just
have it out here doing this stuff I just
I don't understand it man it's like to
me like they didn't make the Lord of the
Rings show to make money there's no
making money you when you spend a
billion dollars that's a passion project
that's like the dude that owns it's like
yo I want my own Game of Thrones type
show here here's a cool billion make me
a great show right and they didn't
they did make a great show
that didn't cost a billion dollars to
make and then they decide to cancel it
I don't understand it I just I don't
you know what I mean I I don't get it
man
I I don't get it but Rick's moving on to
bigger and better things so it's their
loss but it was a really fantastic show
it was very touching very moving very
you know and you know it launched you
know it helped Rick because it launched
him into like he's that guy if you need
somebody you need a
uh good-looking athletic artistic OCD
dude Rick is at the top of the list
don't get a lot of work being that guy
because he's also a a very good actor
um you know he's managing his thing and
it's paying off paying off dividends but
I'm just if it wasn't late right now I
would be even more passionately upset
about this but it is what it is so shout
out to Rick and all the actors and the
creators of as we see it
um you know great job
and you know Amazon not a great job
that was terrible terrible
anyways
I hope everybody's good
um
yeah
you know like I said I'm shooting this
HBO Max thing or shooting this movie so
it was like I gotta get this out so but
anyways let's just go into some of the
things that I wanted to talk about today
um first of all let's go into
where is it I made a thing for it too
just so we can have this
uh is this the one I think this is the
one
let's see boom
is this it no that's the oh here we go
yes
so LeBron James got these great
commercials out where it's him verse
father time but it's Jason Momoa and I
kind of have a problem with it being
Jason Momoa because it's like it just
looked like it's Aquaman you know what I
mean it's like LeBron versus Aquaman
that's what it looked like because he's
so distinctly Jason Momoa or Mimosa or
whatever you know
whatever it is you know what I mean so
um it is funny commercials because you
know LeBron is like how is LeBron he's
gonna be 37 30 I think he's gonna be 38
this year he's I think he's the he has
to be the oldest basketball player to be
playing at a top five in the league
level
at that you know he's got to be the
oldest you know and
I feel like
I feel one I feel bad for LeBron James
because the Lakers are trash all right
and even when the bubble came I felt bad
for LeBron because I was like damn this
dude how much time does he actually have
left to play at a high level to be an
impact player to say win a championship
right well they did it in the bubble so
thankfully he got that but right now
they are squandering his greatness they
did not draft any Shooters they didn't
trade for any Shooters Russell Westbrook
is just I don't know what's up with
Russell Westbrook but he he looks like a
shell of himself it looks like he
doesn't even want to be there nobody
wants that 47 million dollar contract he
he just seems to be like a disagreeable
not a good teammate that's what it's
looking like right now okay and it's a
shame
it's a shame because
it sucks when these older players go out
like this like I'm not a Kobe Bryant fan
rip to Kobe I was never really a fan of
his I was a Kobe Bryant hater I like to
hate on him you know even though he was
you know he was a champion right I hated
to see how he went out with the Achilles
injury within another injury and then
like then the Lakers sucked and he was
just uh he wasn't the same player and he
needed better players around him I would
have liked to have seen Kobe compete in
the end for something real something
meaningful and I think we're seeing that
now with LeBron I think it's sad he's
about to pass Kareem and be the all-time
leading scorer in the league
um ever you know with 40 something
thousand points he's gonna pass Kareem
it would have been nice if he was like
also playing for
you know contending for a championship I
mean that that's the way to go out and
you see this with a lot of players it's
sad so I don't I don't know and then
listen I don't know where you guys stand
with the age-old argument LeBron Jordan
LeBron Jordan who you got I'm a Jordan
guy I'm a 90s kid
but I have no problem with anybody
arguing for LeBron James
he's going to be in in longevity he's
not it's not an excuse because not only
is he playing longer
he also is playing at a higher level for
a long time okay this ain't like Vince
Carter who's still on the team at 40
getting 15 points and contributing but
he ain't the best player on the team
LeBron is legit a top five top seven
basketball players still at this age
that is incredible
he will have beaten Jordan in
practically every statistical category
everyone okay
um four championships 10 appearances
if you want to say LeBron James is the
greatest of all time no more power to
you I like to break it down like this I
think LeBron James has the greatest
career of all time
he has the most
unblemished practically no injuries in
his prime
he he came in the league with hype and
he lived up to it
he took his hometown team to the
championship they didn't win he leaves
he comes back he wins a championship for
them he goes to the Lakers he wins a
championship for them he's a billionaire
as a player
you know
just as a career I don't think there's
anything better than LeBron James from
basketball he has the greatest career
ever
all right
because even if you look at Jordan you
know Jordan had the gambling issues he
had the you know he he retired for two
years I mean there was he was punching
people in the face and you know what I
mean like you know you know what I'm
saying like Jordan had some things when
it comes to like a career so I think
LeBron has the greatest career I think
Jordan is the greatest single talent to
ever play I think if the game's on the
line I'll take Jordan
I'll take Jordan like if we're picking
teams I gotta like this you know
70 of us in in this chat right now if
like you know if five or six of us
decide hey let's draft teams if I had to
first pick I'll take Jordan and whoever
else and I think we're gonna win if
you're talking about drafting from the
greatest players of all time right I
just think that Jordan
in his prime there was no one better in
his prime right so you got the greatest
single player
basketball player Jordan
greatest career
LeBron
the greatest basketball Talent might
even be LeBron
just being six eight six nine with that
speed and and power and jumping ability
and his body you know what I mean it's
it's crazy so I'm bringing this up about
the father time because
excuse me I'm just I feel like
this because this might be it for him
it happens quick you know and he's he's
been injured three years in a row
because you know dude I don't know if
you guys have went out and played
basketball recently I don't care how old
you are if you're not a professional
athlete man or you've played college or
played on organized like that man you go
play one game you are feeling that for
days imagine you gotta go out and play
as a professional athlete it's hard so I
feel like the Lakers are squandering the
last greatness of LeBron and I hate to
see it but father time
is not beating LeBron just yet they in a
good sparring match but this guy
Tom Brady
father time is beating his ass right now
father time is like catching up to him
in off the field on the field and this
is another thing that's sad so if you
think about Tom Brady when he left the
Patriots and went to the Bucks I believe
he was like 41-ish or something like
that 40 so that was still the oldest
football player ever to get to the Super
Bowl and win but that to me was like
that was the best of being old and they
had a great team already ready to go she
went out there and he did it but now
these last three years it has not looked
good it hasn't looked great
team isn't the same not even the same
coach and all his off the field issues
you know with his wife and his family he
made the choice man he was like I want
to play football still and his wife is
like what you need to come take care of
these kids fool and he's like look I
love you but I'm the greatest ever you
know babe I love you you know what I
mean I love the kids I'm providing but
it's like damn girl
you know how many people got seven Super
Bowls it's just me I'm trying to get
eight
I get it
you know what I mean like when you're
when you're someone who's trying to be
successful at something your passion
that's really your first love sadly it's
your first love and everyone else is
your side piece everything else is your
side piece
I understand that energy I fight with it
myself I love working I love look at me
it's freaking 11 55 and my small little
podcast that I keep trying to do and
push I'm still doing it because I feel
obligated I feel a responsibility to do
it I always go to my shows I always try
to put on a good show no matter what's
going on it's like it's just you just
have that thing when you you know when
you're passionate about something no
matter what level you're at no matter
what job it is when you're doing the
thing that you love and you don't feel
like you're working it's the thing that
you live for and it moves you you have
to it's like having that balance between
that and the people that are in your
life that you love and care for and take
care of it's It's it can be challenging
and you know for obviously for him
but I'm I'm as I watch him now I don't
see
I just I I feel like when he had that
first press conference after the first
game when he was like I don't know he
was really kind of doubting he was like
damn I'm 45 I'm about to be 45 and these
22 year olds are clocking me and the
team don't look as good gronk's not here
A B ain't here I don't know if we could
do that I don't know if this is worth
the punishment I think he was thinking
about the injuries that he's had in his
life and he's thinking like man I don't
know if I want to go through this I got
almost 400 million waiting for me from
Fox TV
so
and now he gotta stick with it you know
what I mean like now what can he do
because to me I would be totally cool
with Tom Brady being like yo I made a
mistake y'all less I got I gotta check
out trade for somebody but I gotta get
the hell out of here go get Cooper Rush
from Dallas or you know go get Matt Ryan
because they just benched him in uh uh
uh Indianapolis but I can't do this
anymore so I think father time
is is catching up to
Tom Brady fast you know I think he
caught up to him fast
and that is what it is
um you know so that's
how I feel
about that
all right let me make sure I gotta get
my rap recap music ready to go all right
we're there there we go anyways
um there's many different ways dude
there's a super chat right there all
kinds of ways so that's how I feel about
that but
before we go any further
uh uh wait let me turn this off before
we go any further guys let's talk about
doordash
door
Dash
um
doordash
let's see what's going on you know they
got some Halloween stuff going on um you
know sometimes you got back-to-back
meetings you got errands you need to run
you know you need to go to the
supermarket or you don't have enough
time to cook and you want stuff done you
got a last minute you need to get some
last minute treats even for your
Halloween party you want to get candy
and you want to get all this stuff this
is it
um you know you get a Little Help from
doordash you can get the best Halloween
candy decor and party supplies around
the party supplies I mean that's cool
you look on this app you you select the
things you want boom it comes to you you
need a spooky costume look for that too
you need some Halloween lights how about
that Rachel loves putting like she got
some uh this big spider web that we have
in the downstairs in the living room she
loves to decorate and when she needs
something doordash is what we go to so
um you know if you you need to call
somebody or run out to get some
Halloween treats don't even do that just
instead download the doordash app and
order from one of a thousand local
stores in your neighborhood and get more
treats for all trick-or-treaters
delivered
all right for a limited time our
listeners get 50 off up to 200 up to 220
not 200 up to twenty dollar value and
zero delivery fees when you download the
doordash app and enter code Griffin
that's fifty percent up
to 50 off up to twenty dollar value and
zero delivery fees when you download the
doordash app in the app store and enter
code Griffin don't forget that's code
riffin riffin for 50 off up to twenty
dollar value
and oh they change it to riffin and zero
delivery fees with doordash subject to
change terms uh apply
yeah so I got to make sure I change that
to the code to riffin so thanks thank
you shout out to doordash for being an
awesome sponsor of the show
all right
let me change this real quick y'all
rip it
boom all right
okay let's get back to
regularly scheduled program
um okay so let's get into some reviews
man
uh let's start I'm gonna do Game of
Thrones
last yeah let's do Game of Thrones last
because
Major Spoilers coming your way with that
one
thank you Johnny Del Rome
um
so the first one up is
She-Hulk
I don't know if you guys saw you know
I've been talking about She-Hulk
for
you know let's see I'm talking about
she-hawk for like the whole season and
I'm up and down with it and and even the
way it ended was a little bit it was
okay I mean it was a lot of like talking
to the camera breaking the fourth wall
and so in this final episode She-Hulk
like there's like a finale happening and
Bruce and Bruce Banner shows up the
Hawks shows up and and then she kind of
goes what what is this you know she's
like turns to the camera and she's like
what's going on here this is terrible
she's like I don't want this and then
she sort of breaks through the Disney
plus menu and like goes to like Marvel
Studios as She-Hulk and like Burst Into
The Writer's room and she's all like
what the hell what are we doing and
they're like you know then she's like I
need to I want to talk to whoever's in
charge and then they make it out like
the person in charge is you know this
like this machine like an AI that that
makes all the Marvel movies so it was
kind of cute and you know
um the the main actress Tatiana
maslani is that her name yeah
she's a really great actress like she's
great as She-Hulk you know I I like
following her like she she's really
great actress she's funny she's serious
when she needs to be and and then I feel
like the last few episodes of she-hawk I
really enjoyed the um
like they brought Daredevil you know
they kind of wrapped up the story you
kind of you know it made more sense you
know you were really into her as a
character and uh I enjoyed it suddenly
overall I I recommend the show
all right
I do recommend it so get get you
if you don't have Disney plus and by the
way Disney plus is actually a great
value I think it's the best value and
they're not even a sponsor
but
I use YouTube TV by the way I have
YouTube TV I don't have cable I love
YouTube TV because you get unlimited DVR
and you can watch it anywhere so I'm
always out I got it on my Xbox I travel
and I'm I video game from hotels and I
got YouTube TV on my Xbox and so when
I'm hooked up to TVs in the hotels I'm
looking at my stuff
so that's great YouTube TV is great but
I'll say Hulu is a great value like I
don't know any it is anyone here have
Hulu TV live TV if you haven't let me
know how that is but Hulu's a great
value because you get Hulu you get
Disney plus and you get ESPN app there's
nothing there's no better value than
that one I mean you have the HBO Max you
got Netflix you have all these other
ones which you end up having to all get
I mean I have too many services I got
Paramount plus and you know what by the
way little tip you got to make sure
you're not double dipping
what I found out recently that so I just
downloaded AMC plus because I like I
wanted to watch that show
Interview with a Vampire
really good show by the way I'm going to
start reviewing that one
but so what I didn't realize is on
YouTube TV one of the things I was
paying for was AMC plus I didn't know
that because I went into the got the AMC
Plus app I downloaded it on my Apple TV
and I and I subscribed so I said I paid
for like oh let me pay for this not
realizing that I was already paying for
it on the other thing so make sure you
check all your streaming services and
make sure you get the right deal because
sometimes like for instance I have
YouTube TV HBO Max there's a you can get
HBO Max showtime at stars right as a
bundle but you might be able to get HBO
Max cheaper
connected to a different app or a
different thing that you're doing you
know so there's a lot of different ways
to get all these different apps channels
and stuff that you want to watch so make
sure you're not wasting your money
you know that's just my tip but I I give
I give Seahawk a bunch of woo-woos you
know whoa whoa
whoa
and thank you for the Super Chat
who gave me that Super Chat
let me go to viewer activity
you go to view your activity and I'm so
tired guys I'm so sorry
you know for all my all my listeners
that my you guys that come every week I
really appreciate you and that's why I
did this because I needed to get it in
because I just this is such a crazy week
but thank you Johnny Dell Rome for that
dollar 99 thank you very much
all right so before I go into house of
dragons and finish this up on my short
episode this week I'm having a short one
let us talk about what is it just what
no it's this one
okay there we go
boom
I want to do a little preview of the and
B a season a little short preview I love
the NBA
it's really looking good this year
I'm sad that the Lakers I'm not even a
Laker fan but I am sad for LeBron James
that the Lakers are just trash they're
trash
but as I look at the Western Conference
for instance right now the Trailblazers
are falling out wow like you got the
Trailblazers or Forno Spurs are three
and one the Grizzlies are three and one
Jazz are three and one sons are two and
one Warriors are two and one Clippers
are two and one Pelicans are two and one
you know and then you still got teams
like the Mavericks
um
the Timberwolves and the Nuggets I mean
the nuggets are two and two but they got
Jamal Murray back that team is stacked
and ready to go they got the reigning
MVP I'm just saying you're talking about
the western conference goes legit 11
deep
11 deep western conference goes right
now so that's going to be a battle to
see who gets to the playoffs and what I
love about it is you know you're talking
about it goes to 10 for the playing game
and stuff so a lot of these people have
a chance to get in and Mauricio Savannah
Phaedra thank you if I'm gonna say your
name right but thank you and I haven't
watched werewolf by night that's another
one I need to watch I need to watch
werewolf by night
and I gotta watch Black Adam in the
theaters which I'm gonna do this weekend
when I'm out of town and I'm gonna come
back with reviews of that I'm not a
baseball fan so sorry I don't really
care about baseball you know so that is
what it is so the western conference is
deep as hell and then you go over to the
Eastern Conference man bucks or 2-0
Celtics even with all that drama with
the coach you know you know the coach
sleeping with the President of
Operations or wife like he he slept with
somebody's wife he shouldn't have
basically and so
they gonna fire him they're just trying
to find because you can't find somebody
for that you know whatever
so he I know he got a lawyer they're
trying to figure it out and then as soon
as they can fire him legally they will
but the Celtics are still doing it they
three and one
Hornets I don't think they're gonna
sustain that but they looking good
wizards I don't think they're gonna
sustain it Hawks they're up and down now
the Cavaliers is an interesting team
because they were good last year and now
with the with the Donovan Mitchell
let's go
they look good NYX I don't trust them
Raptors I don't trust them Bulls I don't
trust them and the Nets I don't trust
them Nets are garbage
okay they're garbage all right I've been
talking about this now for two years I
always review it on my podcast I talk
about Durant and Kyrie Irving and and
now Ben Simmons like that this team they
got no defense they got no continuity
they don't even really want to be there
it's just like they they have no big man
that there's no way that team you can't
just win with offense and they're so
scrawny and Ben Simmons just don't got
it like why you playing bro just quit
you got your all your money you have a
few you know you got 10 20 million
dollars in the bank hopefully you got
good Investments and you can just like
just what are you doing you don't want
to play basketball stop playing man
um and then we got
the Pistons and then like the Sixers one
and three and then the heat are one and
three so I don't know what the hell is
going on in the Eastern Conference man
the Eastern Conference is a mess because
you you would think that the better
teams in the East are supposed to be the
heat the Sixers the Nets right those are
and they're in the bottom five they're
in the bottom five so I think in the end
it's gonna be bucks Celtics I think the
Bucks and the Celtics are gonna be the
team and I and I I think my sleeper pick
is Cavaliers
I think the final four of the East I
think the Cavaliers are going to be
there
so
you know we'll see what's going on with
this uh
this NBA season but I really hope that I
really hope that the Clippers
find a way to do it this year they got
everybody they're stacked John Wall John
Wall looks good he hasn't played in two
years three years however long he hasn't
played he got something to prove Kawhi
Leonard's back from his injuries it's
like hey yo dude can we get Kawhi
Leonard finally Paul George I think Paul
George has already proved that he's
ready to go Paul George was balling when
everybody was out so kudos to Paul
George for holding it down but he can't
do it by himself he had 40 the other
night it's time for the Clippers to
finally finally do something man
so we'll see let's we'll see what's
going on there man but um
let's see they have like some Power
Rankings like on the athletic like the
athletic had their power rankings let me
see how what they say with the power
rankings
um
let me show them so they got the Bucks
number one
you know and I I could see that they got
they got a full stack team Boston number
two Golden State Warriors number three
so you know the Golden State Warriors
they looking like they ready to come
back and win the championship again so
we'll see because you know they pay
Jordan pool and they paid Wiggins so I
think this is it for Draymond Green I
think this is the last year you'll see
Draymond Green
um you know so I don't know and oh yeah
by the way yeah I see somebody talking
about Zion Williams like he looked great
but then he got injured like I just
this guy's body it reminds me of Bo
Jackson like Bo Jackson he's he was so
strong and powerful that he tore his own
tendon in his like thigh or whatever it
was and he never was able to play again
but he was that kind of like just
powerful athlete I think that Zion
Williams has the same issue I don't
think his body is designed for
professional sports it's it's great you
know college high school he was doing
all that stuff but when it comes to Pros
with grown ass men playing uh 82 games I
don't think his body's gonna hold up but
we'll see but they looked good but
Ingram got hurt so I don't know and I'm
so sorry for all the people that don't
really care about basketball but it is
what it is Game of Thrones uh House of
dragons review coming next they got
Phoenix the fourth the power ranking
Clippers fifth uh Denver Nuggets six
Dallas seventh and so this is going to
change because Dallas isn't doing that
good in Memphis I mean I just think that
the Western conference right now is the
conference
it's I mean the western conference is
like I like who's gonna come out of
there
like they might have 10
good teams
like even the 10th team was like damn we
should be in the playoffs they might
have a winning record the 10th team I
have a winning record so we'll see
a little ASMR for you
um all right
so that's my mini NBA preview y'all now
spoilers I'm telling you right now this
is the spoiler okay because I want to go
into
Game of Thrones
House of the dragon and it was finally
the season finale
this show
got great
I love it
so as you know they're doing they start
it's 200 roughly around 200 years before
the events of Game of Thrones
and it's about the targaryens who we
know were a menace they were incestual
Dragon riding you know they were calling
they ruled the world type of people that
is always some nonsense going on okay in
that family and they're showing it right
now so and what they've done in the city
in in the series is they doing a lot of
time jumps so they start with some
people who were younger and then they
moved up and then they then they they
jumped five years and they jumped you
know further so now I think we're at
where we're at
so and it's great
you know and they're showing like
you know it's this
thing is so different from the the other
one and you got to ask yourself like how
much of the political climate and social
climate that's going on in the world
right now in Hollywood
affected how they made this show because
ultimately this show has turned into
these two women and their and how they
fight for their families
how they're fighting for their legacy
and their families you know because you
have the princess
raenerys Targaryen you know so she's
great she's like this you know
so like she goes off and she marries the
the the the black blonde people the
valerians or whatever so she's like
decides to marry because they're the
other dry Dragon riding families right
so she goes and marries this dude who's
gay but they haven't understand they
have an arrangement she's like look I
know she basically tells them look I
know you like dick
go do you we're friends we will be happy
you go do you imma do me
but let's have some kids they try to
have kids they claim it didn't work out
so she starts getting with the one of
her guards one of the you know
after she dumped the previous guard
right I skipped all that nonsense so
she's starting to have sex with one of
the captains of the Guard
and she's having these kids who clearly
aren't the black guy blonde hair
they're clearly not his kids you know
what I'm saying like how do you get
around that
so everybody knows it everybody's
calling her a and a bat and all
her kids are bastards right so she got
these two kids okay so then she decides
that she gotta get with Damon her uncle
the king's brother and he's just I don't
know if he's the villain I don't know if
he's a hero but he's a badass
towards the middle towards the end of
the you know the 789 you kind of have a
different feeling for Damon right
so so they get together because they
already have sort of like an incestuous
thing when she was younger and so now
they decide hey we're gonna get together
and try to have babies we gonna get
married but how do we can't get married
while the the black dude is still around
so you think they kill him but they
actually didn't kill him spoiler I told
you this is spoilers they didn't kill
him but they let him go live his life so
he shaves his head and he goes off on a
boat with his one of his new lovers
whatever he's gone but the family thinks
that she and Damon killed him I wish
they actually would have but they did
kill somebody to make it believe that it
was him so they still they still
terrible because you have to think about
that they didn't kill that dude but they
killed somebody because they burned
somebody alive and pretended it was him
okay so
and then Damon was married to
one of the the black girls with blonde
hair the Valerian family and she was
trying to have a baby and she couldn't
have the baby so she goes out there
she's her dragon is the biggest dragon
in the world okay it's a big ass dragon
so she can't have this baby so she goes
out there and she makes her Dragon burn
her alive
so now all right so then you got now you
got the queen who was Princess vanarus
venary whatever her name is the princess
you know so her father the king who's a
really nice man terrible King he
makes her the heir and you all know they
don't want a woman doing it he makes her
the air but the queen his wife who was
her best friend
now she's got her own thing she had a
bunch of kids with the fox with the King
and now she want her kids to be
you know and her father who's the hand
of the king they try to make this kid be
the king but this kid is he is the worst
he's he out here he's raping chamber
Maids he's off in the city having babies
with you know and at the uh at
the brothels and stuff and he's a
sniveling coward you know not his
brother
his brother's a badass which one's the
all right so you got wait let me make
sure I got the names right here I want
to get I want to get them right I don't
know
whatever what what is the brother's name
you know you got aegon
yeah so you got aegon who is he's just a
sniveling coward and then you got the
other one what is his name though
anybody know his name
um
what is this what is the other kids that
they all got the same kind of names
anyway
there's two brothers
one of them don't got a dragon
okay and he's blonde Targaryen
so the black girl who got who burned
herself up who got the biggest dragon in
the world he's this little kid he goes
and claims the dragon he like sneaks
down there gets on the dragon and steals
the Dragon
um
anyway so cut two now they do a time
Jump and the all the kids now are older
and they don't like each other but oh
even I'm sorry before the time Jump you
know the two uh princess kids who would
have brown hair that you know they
clearly from this Captain who you know
he the queen had that dude killed I mean
they both they're all terrible
so the kids are fighting and the the kid
that like
stole the dragon he got his eye taken
out all right so cut to the finale
everybody's older
the one dude who like the the one that
aegon okay so so there's this prophecy
if you watch the show there's a prophecy
about about aegon but that's just a name
that's in the lineage of uh the
targaryens so it's like a bunch of
aegons
so the the the Father the king he
already told princess veneria vernarius
whatever her name is he already told her
about the prophecy and it has to pass
down to the air so on his deathbed he's
got cancer and his face is all riddled
he's sort of talking about the prophecy
and he says aegon King whatever and so
his wife thinks that she the wife thinks
that the king wants his son his natural
born son to to really be the heir and
her father who's the hand of the King
has already been setting this up you
know what I mean so it's you know to to
usurp the princesses right to be Heir
the original Heir so now you cut to the
final finale
and you know they they have already
crowned
you know this sniveling idiot King
and so now they're trying to see who's
going to support her or who's going to
support support you know the other
family the Queen the queen's kids or the
princess's family who is she queen or is
her son King
and then they had this great like you
know so the two young boys of the
princess the brown hair who are the kids
of the kids are the captain who who got
killed they ride dragons and she's like
all right go they want to go hey send us
we're gonna go talk to two different
houses and get support for their mom to
be Queen so one the youngest one he goes
to this one place and the big ass dragon
is in the courtyard because the one-eyed
badass and he should be king by the way
I wish I remembered his name
somebody said dying of cancer in a
fictional world is super tough I mean
right I mean gee whiz dude the king went
out like he what a way to go out but
anyways so the little so the the
youngest son he on his Dragon his little
dragon and he gets there and he's you
know hey my mom you know support her you
know and the other guys there and so it
doesn't go well and then the one-eyed
you know son of the queen he's all like
give me your eye you took my eye I'm
taking your eye
so then
the the how the the head of the house
that they were at he's like hey I don't
want no violence here escort the prince
out so the prince gets on his little
dragon and then the you know the other
dude he he's on the big dragon chasing
him
that was great special effects
this dude's trying to get away I knew he
wasn't gonna get away I knew he wasn't
gonna get away so the big dragon like it
was so big that it gobbled him up you
know
killed him and then like the
last scene the last shot of the show is
is uh
Damon going to his wife the princess his
his niece and his wife
tell her that yo they killed your son
and then she just turns around and she
had just look on her face like
I'm coming for y'all season two
[Laughter]
it was great I don't know if y'all saw
it but I was at the edge of my seat the
whole time was dope
anyways thanks for watching we're from
with Griffin y'all I appreciate it I
really appreciate you guys putting up
with me am I think I'm losing my voice
I'm tired but I had to get a podcast
episode out
um we'll be going with today in terms of
music
let me see I got this dude J dirty I'm
not sure
what his name he sent me a Beat
[Music]
all right y'all
we're gonna finish it up
recap
thanks for coming back
[Music]
oh Pat me on the back
this is
[Music]
that was whack
Amazon this is a big slap
the time
[Music]
that man still playing strong
you know why cause I'm the
[Music]
all right y'all
that was the rap we catch
shout out to Jake dirty thanks for the
beat y'all I'll see you next week
thank you for watching ripping with
Griffin thank you for all the super
chats
and I will see you next
[Music]
thank you